tränen sind worte die der mund nicht
aussprechen kann borussia dortmund
verabschiedet seine legenden marcel
schmelzer sagt nach 17 jahren in
schwarzgelb adieu über 40 jahre prägte
michael zorc den verein als spieler und
als sportdirektor große gefühle und ein
großer umbruch insgesamt acht spieler
verlassen den bvb der zu mancity
wechselnde erding holland wird der
gesamten bundesliga viel hertha bsc will
dagegen unbedingt in der liga bleiben
und bekommt in der 18 minute nach
videobeweis einen elfmeter der gefoulte
tritt selber an i studie mit dem ersten
ausrufezeichen klassenerhalt die gäste
mauern nicht immer regelkonform
handspiel marvin plattenhardt
schiedsrichter tobias stieler
entscheidet erneut auf strafstoß erling
holland sein letzter bvb-treffer
unspektakulär und glücklich durch die
mitte
herter gibt den sicheren klassenerhalt
noch aus der hand yussuf amoco 84 minute
am ende setzt sich die qualität der
hausherren durch felix magath ist
bedient zum zweiten mal in der
vereinsgeschichte muss hertha in die
relegation
durch berlins niederlage kann sich der
vfb stuttgart mit einem sieg gegen köln
den klassenerhalt sichern sasa karadzic
hat bereits in der zwölften minute die
chance auf die führung scheitert aber an
marvin schwebe ist mega parat
der anschliessende eckball und die
verzögerte erleichterung karadzic mit
dem kopf handeln ist eben cleverer
zweiter durchgang dem vfb flattern die
nerven und torhüter florian müller die
hände anthony modeste ist da ausgleich
nicht richtig zugepackt der fc wiederum
greift fest nach europa
abstiegskampf und die großen finales
auch in stuttgart 90 +2 wataru endo alle
aus dem häuschen
stuttgart bleibt erstklassig könnte auf
sich auf die konferenz sieht freuen
[Applaus]
das beste kommt zum schluss
fußball-ikone rudi völler nach abpfiff
noch mal als vorsänger auf dem zaun nach
21 jahren hört der 62-jährige in
sportlichen führungspositionen als
geschäftsführer bei bayer leverkusen auf
christian streich und freiburg wären mit
der direkten europa league qualifikation
zufrieden wenn alles gut läuft ist sogar
noch die königsklasse drin leverkusen
geht allerdings durch lukas allah rio in
der 54 in führung aus freiburger sicht
bleibt es bis zum schluss hochgradig
spannend jamaika barra die hoffnung
champions league sie lebt
doch in einer lange nachspielzeit sieht
palazzo aus dem freiburger kopfkino
endgültig den stecker der sportclub
rutscht auf rang sechs ab noch ein
abschied wieder gänsehaut unions
griechischer krümmel zieht es zu seiner
alten wirkungsstätte tsg hoffenheim
zurück er geht mit wehmut spielen die
eisernen nächste saison doch wieder in
europa und weil der fußball manchmal so
schön kitschig ist darf kümmel in seinem
abschiedsspiel die alte försterei noch
mal zum kochen bringen die partie läuft
auf hochtouren juni per handelfmeter in
der 25 minute
der vfl bochum schaffte am 32 spieltag
bereits den klassenerhalt genießt die
kulisse in köpenick simon zoller erstes
tor für den stürmer nach seinem comeback
nach langer verletzungspause
es ist ein schönes tor festival eduard
löwen 22
für union berlin bleibt lange offen
europa ja nur welcher wettbewerb 88
minute nochmal ein langer ball noch mal
probleme bei der verteidigung boni
doppelpack und nach ab künftige wyss
platz fünf und damit die teilnahme
an der europa league
es wird immer emotionaler bundesliga
kontakt bielefelds rekord torschütze
fabian klos hat seinen vertrag beim
absteiger doch noch um ein jahr
verlängert bevor sie die zweite liga
geht es wird gegen leipzig noch mal groß
aufgezeigt ja nie sera da wackelt der
kasten und das ganze stadion gleich mit
verse außenrist und schließlich die
brust ein tor wie ein arztbesuch
erreicht aufgrund der besseren
tordifferenz ein punkt für die
königsklasse der lässt aber lange auf
sich warten willi orban 90 +3 im
sechsten bundesliga zum fünften mal für
die champions league qualifiziert bei
eintracht frankfurt dreht sich alles um
das europa-league-finale am mittwoch in
sevilla tabellarisch geht es auch um
nichts mehr im derby gegen max die
gastgeber sind motivierter markus in
wersen mit der führung in der zehnten
minute
mainz dominiert die partie in allen
belangen und dann wie so oft der
ausgleich irgendwie aus dem nichts
fehler von damen die war eintracht ein
bisschen dusel bitte noch für das finale
aufbewahren raphael stellt den
spielverlauf nach mehr als einer halben
stunde auf den kopf die stimmung passt
die treffsicherheit auf
zweiter durchgang zwei treffern 1 in
bozen das 2 2 auch der endstand die
europa league helden aus frankfurt sind
damit in der bundesliga seit acht
partien sieglos
der vfl wolfsburg hat sich nach einer
enttäuschenden saison von trainer
florian kufeld getrennt auch für julia
nagelsmann war in seinem ersten jahr bei
den bayern mehr drin die stimmung im
verein ist trotz meisterschaft seit
wochen angespannt gegen wolfsburg
gefühlt noch einmal zusammenreißen josef
stanisic eins zu null erstes bundesliga
tor für den jungen kroaten in seinem
vierzehnten einsatz vor allem die
zukunft von robert lewandowski hat für
unruhe gesorgt stand sonntagabend ist
alles weiter offen fest steht dagegen
saisontor 35
der angreifer wird zum fünften mal in
serie
bundesliga-torschützenkönig
wolfsburg verkürzt vor der pause jonas
wind vom max kruse in szene gesetzt
kuhse sorgt dann auch für den ausgleich
in der 58 minute irgendwie ist es für
alle beteiligten ein ernüchternder
letzter spieltag
[Applaus]
markus weinzierl hat mit seinem
rücktritt nach der partie für einen
paukenschlag beim fc augsburg gesorgt
für absteiger greuther fürth geht es nur
noch um das unterfangen wenigstens einen
auswärtssieg in der bundesliga holen in
fremden stadion bleibt dem kleeblatt das
glück aber verwirkt daniel caligiuri vom
punkt mit seinem fünfzigsten bundesliga
tor
der tabellenletzte will sich bord lich
verabschieden jazz weekend gone kam kann
für tun doch in der ferne feiern
nein auch nicht am 34 spieltag michael
gregor iec hat noch einen der fca
gewinnt das spiel und verliert seinen
drink
auch adi hütter verabschiedet sich bei
borussia mönchengladbach in seinem
letzten spiel erlebte österreicher ein
furioses tor festival gegen hoffenheim
gladbach zunächst mit viel staat andré
kramer rich in der dritten minute
und dann wird es unterhaltsam auch weil
alles an player auftritt ein entstehen
lässt baumann das klatschen lars stindl
hellwach
in der 44 minute übernimmt player
verantwortung vom punkt
spiel gedreht kurz vor der pause
und weil es so schön ist gibt's den
single vor der kabine nochmals zu hören
florian neuhaus wunderschön für jonas
hofmann gladbach kann so guten fußball
spielen und
das wird dann auch nach dem
seitenwechsel demonstriert hofmann für
brill embolie ein passt zum zunge
schnalzen und dann auch noch ein lupfer
auf einmal ist alles so einfach
auch weil die tsg als zuschauer in der
ersten reihe sitzt hofmann mit ganz viel
gefühl
und ein gitter oliver baumann
hoffenheim beendet die spielzeit mit
neun bundesligaspielen ohne sieg und adi
hütter mit einem torreichen abschieds
die ergebnisse des letzten spieltages in
der übersicht
neben vielen toren gab es viele
verabschiedungen manche sehr emotional
anderem er überraschend
die abschlusstabellen gratulation an den
deutschen meister bayern münchen
dortmund leverkusen und leipzig spielen
champions league union und freiburg
ziehen in die europa league ein köln
geht in der europakonferenz league an
den start dank endos treffer bleibt der
vfb stuttgart in der bundesliga hat der
bsc muss in der relegation gegen den hsv
antreten
[Musik]